[Music]
glasses
mustache beanie who the hell is this guy
i forgot to buy new contact lenses okay
we're gonna do it like this
i also forgot to record videos i'm so
[ __ ] tired
memes let's get into them yeah
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old
and i'll measure your pp's in the last
episode
there is no game i feel like i played
this before five years ago
there is no game but it's a different
game
it's a different game yeah i wouldn't
forget oh my god i did the same
thumbnail idea i lit
it's good to know you learned a couple
of tricks in five years
i use the same title there is no video
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh it was out on
new grounds i even linked to it
i'm so nice hey how's it going
well today we're playing there is no
game
that's all i know about this game that
there is no game user
i i have bad news oh god
actually there's no game well that's not
a
surprise i hope you're not too much
disappointed
and then now okay that has to be
something with these then
uh how did my my quality get worse
at least camera quality got better you
can't you can't lie to me about that one
it took me five years to get to this
i mean he wasn't lying there is no video
something went wrong tap true to retry
oh yeah youtube went down or something i
didn't i was asleep when it happened
but that's crazy sorry guys i broke
youtube
my bad what a crazy timing there is no
video
there is no video what'd i say
youtube just needs to work come on
spiderman
miles morales europeans spider-man
kilometer morales
europeans you guys are really funny
you guys are really clever right what do
you want me to do with tambourine
hey felix a doctor here just saw your
reason
knuckle red and swollen and
what the hell that's usually a sign that
you do in fact have blood in your body
just that oh my god
thank you i am not a vampire this is
great
i don't know how i got it that's the
weirdest part going on some crack
journeys
i was sawing and i think i was rubbing
against the wall but
it looks so much worse than it should
have been i don't know
employees who should get in the shower
dudes
[Laughter]
oh god i'm sorry past employees that's
the only reason i'm not sharing that
story for so long
is because i i feel like the statue of
limitations or whatever it's called
it's it's at least 10 years so i'm just
sitting in someone's shower after that
you can tell them
and they are not allowed to be mad at
you i think that's fair
i think this if you can get in someone's
shower for 10 years
and they don't figure out it's you it's
all fair game
go after my what so what i'm saying is
go out there
get in showers do what you got to do and
if you didn't watch last
week's episode this will sound very
gross and confusing there's a perfect
reasonable story behind it you just have
to
okay sorry your crush her father
her brother her ex her first love
you and what the [ __ ] does that mean at
least you have g-fuel
right
see not tired anymore it's a work
pewdiepie when edgar falls
pewdiepie went my fault my fault that
sounds like a
waterfall or something yeah i'm a sim
for maya what can i
say i think it's safe to say that anyone
that gets hundred thousand uploads would
automatically get to hosh
meme review oh my god
all my deputies you got a hundred
thousand uploads
are you [ __ ] kidding me i forgot
about that jesus christ
i mean fair game cave scythe if you want
to host meme review
by all means i'll set you up with some
epic memes
we have a legendary rooster of people
hosting meme review
blue shirt kid justin roiland
the baby at the bus feelings
this makes make no sense if you didn't
watch the last weeks after
that's exactly the look holy [ __ ] i
am a dad everyone's saying i look like
that with mustache but holy that proves
it
what the [ __ ] those misleading puzzle
ads you see everywhere are now banned
you know you probably get these ads
because you click on them you dumbass
don't blame the ad blame your brain
explain your reckless clicking online i
have a big click on anything but you're
watching this video right now
yeah i got you i got you huge in case i
thinking they are appreciating each
other's art by giving
costly awards meanwhile i've read it no
give me back my coins thanks
i had so much money can give community
awards for free
also appears when he sees something he
likes the best i can do is big peeping
wait why i don't understand reddit i
don't
get it i don't get ready even though
this is largely a reddit channel i don't
understand anything
that relates to reddit what the [ __ ] is
award and why do i want one
so these are free is that correct i feel
like i'm getting tricked here
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
these awards man you gotta spend that's
the best i can do
gekko long 1945 i wonder if he's still
out there
dick long are you out there
long calling jake long how old was he
being right now
if he was uh what 16 17 he's got to be a
real [ __ ]
dick long we need you to host meme
review
dick vlog dick long
1945 this size
wait did they have colored photos in
why does it say 1945 thank you dick long
you tricked me thank you
rick and morty predicted pewdiepie wow
incredible it's the new simpsons
how do they keep doing it i don't get it
it's crazy
[Laughter]
fix it feelings yeah
trust me i ain't never fixing anything
again god damn i'm so tired
we spent the last three days laying uh
floor
and oh my god so much work i am so tired
that's why i'm so tired today
i'm an australian and i tried pewter's
workout routine this is my transform
god damn nice looking biceps
bro hell yeah
you can yoke this
[Music]
start lifting weights immediately and
stop
crying you weirdo [ __ ] swedish youtuber
has gained millions of subscribers by
uploading frequent commentary about what
she had the choice between cats cooking
and video game and she went with cooking
how would you like your eggs damn
fertilized
what the [ __ ] what's wrong with you guys
carson looks like
homer simpson i look like ned flanders
it's a match made in heaven
i do get a lot of ask for collabs and
not speak about carson but
whenever there's a collab that goes
through someone's agent or like my
manager
i'm like nah nah no [ __ ] way that's
so corporate what the [ __ ] are you doing
just ask me
hey felix we would like to collaborate
we think it will do great for you
thank you i think you forgot the part
where i'm socially awkward
hey pewter can i have my salary for last
month
oh yes i almost forgot about that you
get 10 tambourine slaps well done
10 that's a lot psy you should be
thankful
i pay psy by the way just so we're clear
with time ring slaps of course ah
hell yeah
damn damn i felt that to my core
my cool oh god damn yo
he he'd be looking like uh [ __ ]
looked like
mark wahlberg am i wrong holy [ __ ]
mark wahlberg made a coke melon intro
okay
[Laughter]
say it what the
holy [ __ ] that's so cool
oh this is not a coco melon intro it
just hit me it's just a random guy
all right i was like that's the most
impressive one so
far isn't made by you guys it all makes
sense now
i'm joking by the way okay don't stop
crying stop crying you gotta
look it [ __ ] found monkey
monkey 160 millions
you monkey felix after sitting in the
shower and making his co-workers
uh all right i didn't know they had to
clean it up okay
just so we're clear i didn't know i mean
in retrospect it was obvious
i was poisoned you understand me
watching pewds recovering from prostate
cancer
surgery robotic thanks for supporting
movember raising awareness prostate
cancer and men's health
look after yourself 19 year olds looks a
bit above my demographic
oh that's sweet wish you a speedy
recovery bet you feel bad making fun of
the mustache now huh
yeah it's for a good cause my mom's
reaction to the mustache was the
funniest she just went
you know when moms don't want to say
anything just do not hurt your feelings
and they it's just written on their face
[Music]
i'm like it's for prostate cancer
awareness oh okay that's so nice
you're so nice i wish i could find a guy
like you i
am a guy like me yeah but you're ugly
[Music]
god damn that beef is all roasted up
that beef ain't wrong hey hello i drove
pissed that's amazing
hey let's give an award shall we you get
uh the most expensive
award of all time the most prestigious
snake award you are welcome
thank you that's right that's a legit
art thank you so much watching piers
video always make me feel better this is
a random pic i found on google
uh can we use the markiplier one come on
[ __ ] pewdiepie would make a better
rewind anyway hey i don't make them
the boys make them calling the boys oh
yeah
youtube announced that they're not doing
rewind this year because
of all the badges that happened which
probably makes sense
if you think about it but also it would
have been nice to see it anyway it's
like a
thing everyone comes together and just
some for no reason at this point
my mom telling me how i'm a failure me
who got to the y
10 times see that legit you could put
this on your resume if you're applying
for
i don't know some shitty social media
job you can put lawyer on your resume
i'll i'll even sign it for you if you're
legit about it
i'll be a reference feeling should check
out swedish pro
what no [ __ ] way there's a swedish
problem
oh hell yeah is that oh yeah all right
let me guess
cuckery what the [ __ ] is this oh it's
all in swedish
i have to translate i bought a
watermelon what the f
why oh what'd i tell her cuckery
that was right oh man things could have
been different if i wasn't born a swede
or a different kind the rest of the
world don't understand
people who don't respect other people's
property
oh my god it's so sweetish when will you
stop
uploading when i'm dead when i'm gonzo
it sounds like you're happy about me
dying thank you thank you meme
appreciate yes finally
what we see what feelings
little kids are rude i can't help it all
right
i'm gay i can't help it shelburg road
what off what though why shelby road is
real
what the what what the [ __ ]
schellberger wrote i've been damned if
there's a shadowberry road
holy flicking molly where is it
australia holy moly smoothly that's
crazy
shelburg chiropractic manipulative
therapist
who are you i know you're watching it's
us
there's an imposter shelburg road
shelburg shadow road jumbo road
let's go let's go come on there's no
street view
uh too bad australia isn't real we all
know this already
found this road in australia wait so you
just stumbled
you just walked past in mila mila you're
telling me
you're telling me ah you're telling me
that you just strew down old
pam sturgeon and then you were like i
got
oh wait oh oh oh oh maybe we can find it
there it is a beauty a shelled burger
road
oh my god it's so beautiful ah no i
can't enter
no till my room
settle by road take me home
to that place where i belong
we should build the tambourine tower to
the moon there yes
once we get funding from elon musk it's
very close
trust me he's just got to sign all the
papers we'll settle on shelby road
uh generation after generation it's a
pleasure to game alongside you happy
launch day playstation
i miss when companies just hated their
guns guess i'm the only one
studies all night for exam my brain
during exam that's crazy
sometimes i would study all night for an
exam and i would be
insanely sharp i don't know how i did it
i performed some of my best exams just
by not sleeping which goes against all
science
i don't get it i was i was always too
excited before exams
that was a nerd god damn it gaming
december
is coming prepare yourself gaming month
oh
[Laughter]
i waited three months for this shirt my
my merch finally came in and the same
week as my birthday the way it went
[Laughter]
i just know that she did this hey
hey hey oh yeah
it took three months to get the shirt
what the happy belated birthday
just reminder that this exists 2015
simpler times good times was that pax
i think so it was before i was outlawed
so
maintain social distancing
i get it i get maths
i beat pewdiepie at his own game
well played that that actually takes a
long ass
time i like how they programmed someone
always about these series
well done well done
you did it congratulations
the two boys on their own they're boys
together
oh yeah our powers combined
makes us stronger than ever the amazon
delivery thinking why hasn't the
tambourine guy ordered in a while
i'm sorry i don't need more tambourines
i
really i think i'm good on a lifetime me
has never heard of unasanos also me
after seeing all the memes on reddit
f he was like further to me wait so what
uno is honest isn't that a bit redundant
like everyone has to want anus
it makes no sense i challenge you beards
that's adorable
i'll send it to marcia it's time oh yeah
oh look at that
look i wore the finishing fur shirt it
helped me build better
it made me go creative mode are we still
selling them i kind of forgot to promote
them
no i guess not my take out what's that
[ __ ] sake next year i'll do it again and
i'll do it right
i'm so disappointed you can't understand
i was this close to greatness
why did you edit out my voice i thought
my voice was so good
my channel so how do you rate memes
pewdiepie from big to small
the only way to categorize them
oh oh what the [ __ ] hey that's so cool
well done the vikings were the first
europeans to discover america and not
christopher columbus
you're welcome guys all americans you're
welcome
we did it we created america
wait does this mean vinland saga is real
what it's based on true story
that's a good fat art i had to do what i
had to do
all right enough enough enough
thank you for watching this week
always a great pleasure look at graf you
know what to do
see you guys in the next one brofist
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings